ralph i'm coming to you first because i
want to ask about
filming in okinawa for real this time
was there anything about
the production process and the way
things work over there that might have
come as a surprise um
it was wonderful it was uh a whirlwind
we uh i'm really uh thankful and proud
of the production and sony for letting
us
go there for what was only about two
days of shooting
it was like a long weekend uh
most of the time was in the air we uh
it was blessed you know it just felt
like i was in the land of miyagi you
know and i finally got there and yuji
was with me
uh tamlin did not get to go so messed up
with
uh kumiko we we were able to shoot uh
stateside if you will
and it we had one gorgeous day of
weather
and one just miserable day of weather
and
we were able to just cherry pick and get
get what we needed some of the you know
we landed
and the wardrobe was on another plane
that it
was transferred so that we had to match
a shirt because it didn't make it there
in time and we only had two days and
all that stuff that you hear about on
the dvd extras
um is what i'm giving you and but it was
that one beautiful location overlooking
uh the the landscape and the water was
just
it it felt uh blessed to be there
you know and it's just a nice thing to
have well worth jumping through all
those hoops to make that stuff happen
those scenes are really rich in the
season i think
what about just reuniting with uh yuji
and tamlin is there anything
about working with them that hasn't
changed even after all these years
it was it's it's the same thing i talk
about when billy and i stepped on
together there's a
there's just a history and you share
something that's even an
unspoken language that um that there's a
connection
and with uh tamlin uh she just said
both of them it's such a beautiful job
brought their a games
the tamil and it was like we were uh
these teenagers you know it's smiley and
it was
sweet and it was angelic and all those
those things that you remember
from that film we couldn't help but be
that way
and uh and it lends itself to the story
as that line where he says it's been 30
years but it feels like five minutes
and it feels that way with felt that way
with both of them and eugene does such a
spectacular turn
in his character and he knows where the
comedy is
and the action and the drama and the
heart and that all comes through
with both of them so i'm really proud to
have that in this season because it
also propels the story the
larusso johnny lawrence story it's not
just there as a standalone
it's um how do you deal with a rival and
how can you get to the other side
so he learned something so now billy one
of the things that admittedly i was most
worried about
with season three was the ability to
maintain the levity that the show
had while also respecting the severity
of
miguel's injuries so what was it like
trying to find that right balance while
you guys were shooting the hospital
scenes
well listen you never play comedy for
comedy the comedy is in the uh blind
obsession the
kind of uh just uh it's not meant to be
comedy really but
uh you know there's drama it's funny the
way they the writers wrote
uh johnny rehabbing miguel and trying to
get him back on his feet
um just that alone is funny um
uh so uh yeah the there's a there's a
definite levity to the seriousness of
the injury and what he has to go through
the rehab
um but uh you know it bounces back and
moves forward i also really love
watching the relationship between miguel
and johnny grow from season to season
and
i also have a thing about asking about
the value of having a good scene partner
so
i'm also curious about hearing about how
your relationship with show low has
grown from
season to season yeah i mean
it's been so natural with him he's such
a great actor and working with him is
really effortless he just snapped in and
found this character and
uh even in our auditions when we did our
auditions uh for him
um and uh what happens between show low
and
and billy is awesome and johnny and
miguel
uh is in the writing and i'm amazed
always watching it i love watching that
relationship
too and um what they what they mean to
each other how they need each other
um and they're they're so different but
so so
uh you know they have they have this
love this father-son love between them
and
um that that's awesome you know works
both ways
it's awesome to work with show low and
uh to watch where that relationship's
going
i had to pinch myself while i was
watching it seriously i don't know how
you guys exceeded my
expectations again but thank you so much
congratulations and